um I haven't really been looking at this
puzzle I've given it some time already
for you guys to crunch the numbers I
don't know what the solution is so I'm
just really like I would do in a live
blitz game really just gonna share with
you my train of thought right now my
first thought is something about the b7
square and the reason I'm focused on
that is because of the tension between
it attacked once defended once in fact
maybe the very first thing to really
point out is one that is something that
I've shared many a times in my videos on
YouTube and that is unprotected pieces
leads to tactics in fact one of the one
of the very one video I posted was the
chess awareness test and in that video I
spoke about how squares that are let's
say are in this in this case right here
this palm it's attacked once it's
defended once you might as well already
regard that in your own mind as being
unprotected and oftentimes the solutions
to these puzzles I've done I mean I've
been at the game for a while so I mean
I've seen my share of puzzles but a lot
of the attention should really be
focused on the unprotected pieces
because that's usually going to be
leading to tactics in some way so that
set in all these puzzles I'm really
going to be focusing my eyes on those
particular squares so b7 has my
attention my first thought is Queenie 4
because it's threatening me another
other type of moves I'd be looking for
are moves where there are two or more
pieces that can go to it so that said
both Queen and Bishop can be making use
of this square and I
think there's actually something to this
I think I'm actually close to an answer
because the Queen or the bishop could
play here and both are immune from
capture because of just mate another
thing when it comes to puzzles is that
[Music]
you know we don't know we don't know
what they're looking we don't know if
it's a mate
we're just it's basically presented to
us as best continuation but if it were a
main to problem one of the first things
like if they said it to matin - for
white one of the very first things I'd
look for is what it is black can do or
in other words in this case can black
give check to white and they can so that
said it's a you know we could be making
a quiet move one that doesn't wasn't
doesn't give quiet move one that does
not give check in other words I'm
looking at some suggestions in the chat
and I think there's got to be another
interesting one is I think I'm an
agreement with just a rough thought here
I'm thinking along the lines of what the
bloodlines has said I think there's
something about this Queen a six move
what a sharp move that is huh with the
idea here there's Queen a six with what
it's a very clear threat of mate on b7
after Queen a six what are blacks
options b6 is not an option because of
Bishop c6 followed by made on b7 Queen
a6 rook b8 the idea here is there's
something with Queen takes pawn leading
to mate I believe I have the solution
and it's uh not without maybe some help
like I guess I kind of peeked at the
chat here but I think the solution is
Queen a6 and after rook b8 what would
then be the follow-up after Queen a6
rook b8 what do you do
what's that follow-up anybody know what
would it be and this is where
calculation comes in because what I
could very easily do right now is just
move Queen a6 and the computer will play
as black it'll it'll pick some random
move or you know something that's going
to put up resistance but then we're just
kind of only ever looking one move deep
but how about trying to see the
variation through to its end calculation
I think I'm liking Queen a6 because of
the possibilities of Queen takes a seven
I think I have the solution but any
other thoughts you might have Queen a6
I'm pretty sure rook b8 is a necessity
the knight is out of play there are no
checks against the King the Queen cannot
move and defend this Square Queen a6
rook b8 and I think I am with at least
I'm seeing well many many people are
pointing out I think the follow up is
then Bishop c6 let's give it a shot
is this correct it is correct it's
saying it on the right you can't see it
but it does say that it's correct
otherwise we would just go back and now
I believe Bishop c6 is going to be
brutal
the idea here Bishop c6 what do we do
after Bishop c6 Queen c8 I think I
probably already gave this one away
Bishop c6 Queen c8 defends against b7
I'm pretty sure this is the next best
move
we could have seen pond takes but then
it's million two after Queen takes and
then queen bee queen bee seven and now
somebody is saying crook a one right
idea but not the correct order force
almost first boom this is a mate in one
- problem solved